-Our next guest
is a talented actress
you know from such shows
as "E.R." and "Six Feet Under."
She stars in the Netflix remake
of "One Day at a Time."
The third season
begins streaming Friday.
Let's take a look.
-None of those things are legal
for you 'cause you're 15.
-It's just a fun thing we do
once in a while.
Anyways, I get straight A's.
-Well, you won't for long
if you're a stoner.
-I'm not a stoner.
We laugh at those guys.
Besides, tons of successful
people have smoked weed --
Barack Obama, Steve Jobs, Oprah.
-Unemployed, dead, and Gayle
just said that to get ratings.
-Please welcome to the show,
Justina Machado, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Hi, Justina.
How are you?
-Hi! I'm good.
I'm good.
-Congratulations
on season three.
You know, for people
who don't watch this show,
this is both
a traditional sitcom,
but it also --
You know, it tackles issues
that are very modern.
You play a Cuban-American,
war veteran, single mom,
dealing with PTSD.
Were you --
Could you kind of not believe
when you first started
seeing the scripts
exactly how, you know, real
the material was gonna be?
-Yeah, because, of course,
the first thing
that drew me to it
is that Norman Lear
was making a remake,
and I'm like "Norman Lear?
Of course, I'd love to work with
Norman Lear and Rita Moreno."
So, I hadn't even
read anything yet,
but when I had
to go read for him,
and they gave me the script,
is when I discovered,
"Wow, this is amazing."
This is such
a layered monologue.
There's so much in here.
You know, so many times
as a Latina actress,
you're put in boxes, you know?
It's either you're like
the oversexualized Latina
or you're the asexual cop
or you're the suffering mother,
or you're all of these things,
and it was this woman
who was just layered
and just fantastic
and had so much humanity.
So, yeah.
It was incredible.
-And here is Norman, right here.
-Yes.
-You wouldn't think he's the guy
who's gonna help
a Latina be multi-layered.
[ Laughter ]
But there he is.
[ Applause ]
One of the best of all-time.
-He is.
He has a lot of help
from our wonderful showrunners,
Gloria Calderon Kellett
and Mike Royce, so, yes.
-Yeah.
-Yes. Definitely.
-And it was lovely to meet
Gloria backstage, as well.
-I know.
She came to support me!
-The first season
led up to a quinceañera.
You had one.
-I did.
I had a really
ghetto quinceañera.
-Now, how so?
-Well, you know,
I'm from a working-class family
in the inner city of Chicago,
and we didn't have
a lot of money.
So, my mother was like,
"No, you're not having
a quinceañera,"
and I thought, "Yes, I am
having a quinceañera."
And I went around, and I asked
every family member for money,
and even my cousin
made the dress for me.
We rented this ghetto hall
on North Avenue in Chicago --
in Chicago, called Norvell,
and upstairs from the hall
was a hotel for hookers.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So while I was -- while
my guests are walking out,
the hookers were coming in.
-Wow!
-And it was like,
"Yeah! This is good."
So you could imagine how much
the teenagers loved it.
-Here it is!
This is a beautiful photo.
-Come on.
Look at this.
-Yeah.
-Look at that hair.
[ Laughter ]
Look at those things.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, that isn't cute.
-You recently posted this photo
of how you used to love Prince
and that you ended up kind of
just, like, becoming Prince.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
That's fantastic.
-I mean, look at that.
But the sad thing is, I was
trying to look like Madonna.
-Really?
-Yes, yes.
-You aimed for Madonna
and hit Prince?
[ Laughter ]
-I did. Oh, my God!
That's hilarious.
I did.
-We met years ago because
we have a friend in common.
You've known him
a lot longer than I have.
Horatio Sanz.
-Horatio Sanz.
-You knew him
from Chicago, as well.
-I did.
I've known him since
I was 18 years old, and we call
him Roger in Chicago.
-Yeah.
-So, I might go back and forth.
So, yeah.
Roger and I --
Horatio and I -- Sorry.
Horatio and I,
we were in the same
theater company together,
and funnily enough,
we auditioned
for "In Living Color"
together,
and we both thought
we were gonna get in.
We just knew we were gonna
get in "In Living Color."
I went to the audition with
a bunch of props but nothing.
Like, I had --
-Like, no material.
-I had no material.
-Okay, gotcha.
-But I had a big styrofoam penis
that I thought
would really work.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
You didn't know what
you were gonna do with it?
You just thought,
"This is a good thing to have."
-It's is a good thing to have.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, we both kind of bombed,
and I remember sitting down,
talking to each other,
and I said, "Don't worry, Rog.
You're one of
the funniest guys I know.
One of these days, you're gonna
be on 'Saturday Night Live.'"
And then it happened,
and I said, "Wh-a-a-at?"
[ Laughter ]
I should've
said that about myself.
What?
[ Laughter ]
-And he was like,
"And if they ever reboot
'One Day at a Time'..."
-Exactly.
"You're the Bonnie Franklin."
Exactly.
-And you get
to work with Rita Moreno.
That just must be amazing.
-Oh, she's fantastic.
I mean, she's exactly
what you would imagine.
She's a living legend.
-Yeah.
-And she's
so dynamic and energetic,
and she's
an incredible acting partner
and just a wonderful
human being to be around.
So, yeah, it's great.
It's great all around.
-Well, congratulations.
I'm so happy it's back,
and I'm so happy
you're doing it.
And thanks so much
for being here.